so you're a student of History if I can
just Linger on that philosophical notion
of hate
that part of human nature if you look
at
World War II what do you learn from
human nature from the rise of the Third
Reich and the rise of somebody like
Hitler and the hate that permeates that
well what I've learned is that you have
to nip bad things in the bud you have to
uh there's a Latin term that says
stop bad things when they're small and
the deliberate hatred the the uh
incitement of hatred against uh one
Community uh it's demonization
delegitimization that goes with it uh is
a very dangerous thing and that happened
in the case of the Jews what started
with the Jews soon spread to all of
humanity so what we've learned is that's
what we should we should never and I
never set aside and say oh they're just
threatening to destroy us they won't do
it if somebody threatens to eliminate
you as Iran is doing today and as Hitler
did then and people discounted it well
if somebody threatens to an eyelid I'll
take them seriously and act to prevent
it early on don't let them have the
means to do so because that may be too
late
so in those threats underlying that
hatred how much of it is
anti-zionism and how much of it is
anti-Semitism I don't distinguish it
between the two you can't say well I'm
okay with Jews but I just don't think
there should be a Jewish State it's like
saying I'm not anti-American I just
don't think there should be an America
that's basically what what people are
saying vis-a-vis
anti-anti-semitism and anti-zionism
when you say anti-zionism you're saying
the Jewish people don't have a right to
have a state of their own uh and that
that is a denial of uh of a basic uh
a basic principle that I think
completely
unmasks what is involved here today
anti-Semitism is anti-zionism those who
oppose the Jewish people oppose the
Jewish state